California police are investigating
whether the suspected Golden State
Killer is responsible for a double
murder that sent an innocent man to
prison
Rhonda wick and her four-year-old son
were killed in their apartment in 1978
her ex-boyfriend Craig Coley was
exonerated last year after nearly four
decades in prison Carter Evans spoke
with Coley he's at the semi valley
police department that's outside of Los
Angeles Carter good morning good morning
DNA evidence proved Craig Coley
was not a murderer it also unmasked
Joseph D'Angelo as the alleged Golden
State killer now investigators here are
hoping it will solve a forty-year-old
mystery they were dear to me I love them
and I never had time to grieve their
death 70 year old Craig Coley spent more
than half his life behind bars for a
double homicide he did not commit now
investigators are wondering if the crime
might be linked to Joseph D'Angelo the
alleged Golden State Killer suspected in
12 murders and more than 50 rapes across
California Coley was wrongfully
convicted in the deaths of his ex
girlfriend Rhonda wick who was raped and
strangled and her four-year-old son
Donald who was suffocated do you think
the Golden State killer could be
responsible that's a possibility I think
that there are other suspects that are
more likely what if he does turn out to
be the killer
well it'll be solved you know maybe if
maybe the family can rest maybe they can
relax how about you I could care less
about him Simi Valley police have asked
for a comparison of D'Angelo's DNA with
wicks actual killer Joseph may is the
department's deputy chief the DNA will
tell the true story once it's compared
we'll be able to tell whether or not he
was involved D'Angelo has already been
charged with two murders in Ventura
County where Simi Valley is located he
allegedly killed Lymon and Charlene
Smith in 1980 two years before wick and
her son were murdered it doesn't come
back a match we have other leads that
we're looking at one thing is it'll be
good that we know we've eliminated a
suspect last year police recovered
long-lost crime-scene evidence and tests
for DNA technology not available at the
time of Coley's trial the results ruled
Koli out as the murderer former Simi
Valley detective Michael bender helped
win Coley's freedom he quit the police
department in 1991 because he was
convinced Koli was innocent and then
devoted his life to trying to prove it
he's also curious about D'Angelo knowing
everything you know about the
investigation in your heart of hearts do
you think that DNA is gonna match I
would be surprised but I'm happy to be
wrong which sister is also skeptical the
DNA will match she told CBS this morning
based on what we know about the Golden
State killer's mo it's doubtful Carter
Thanks